what's up y'all i'm joelle and for the
next week i am going to attempt to eat
like the incredible iconic sensational
korean boy band
bts my friend jasmine over on tasty
recently made a video
detailing how to make one of each
member's favorite dishes so i was
inspired to deep dive even further into
the lives of
seven of my favorite humans and try to
eat some of their favorite foods
throughout the week dedicating one day
to each member
if i've learned anything from the many
hours of behind the scenes footage and
live streams of them i've watched
it's that they are hard workers and big
eaters so i need to go do some grocery
shopping and i'll see y'all soon
it only felt right to start out with
ramsday who is kind of seen as bts
his leader he is a crazy talented rapper
i thought i would start out the day
with a lovely korean pastry this one is
filled with sweet bean paste
and a v live jimin and rm were making
talcona coffee
and they're trying to whip it by hand to
vary degrees of success so i decided to
make my own
whenever my family gets these they
disappear so fast so good
why don't we kick off the day with our
bts fun fact
bts stands for bangtan soniadan which
translates
in english to bulletproof boy scouts and
it's meant to symbolize how the group is
immune to these stereotypes
assumptions and critiques about young
people today i am so excited for lunch
because apparently
rm loves kaguksu which is also one of my
favorite dishes it is korean
knife cut noodle soup look at all the
noodles
i just flowers on my face when you order
this at restaurants in korea a lot of
times they'll bring it to you in a
like huge bowl for the table i always
reached a midday slump around like
three-ish so it's a good time for me to
have my snack i know
that rm is happy to eat gummy bears
at all hours of the day i think there
was an episode of one of the reality
shows where he was literally eating
gummy bears first thing in the morning i
don't think i could do that to my
stomach
but as an afternoon treat why not
so the last meal for ramsday is just as
iconic as he is
and that is sam gupta which is korean
grilled pork belly it's really common to
get
any korean barbecue place served with
rice normally to wrap in red leaf
lettuce or kenny
which is perilla leaf and you always
have it with panchen which is all the
little cream side dishes and you eat it
all together
and it is absolutely delicious but if
you want to be really pro with it you
would take your leaf take your meat
one of my favorite things that i learned
about rm is that he
taught himself english through watching
reruns of friends
when i think about how many hours of
kdrama or anime i've watched with
retaining
next to zero korean or japanese that's
really impressive good for you man
proud of you jimin is one of the group's
vocalists and he is a
beautiful dancer and he's also known for
just having the sweetest little face
which has given him the nickname mochi
which i feel like is
very fitting starting out super simple i
think it was in a buzzfeed video
actually that jimin said that he really
likes eating fruit so i just find myself
a cute little fruit platter jimin said
that he loves meat particularly beef so
i wanted to make some googly which is
really just marinated
korean beef but i didn't think it'd be
enough on its own so i combined it in
some bibimbap which is
a korean dish of mixed rice with a lot
of veggies
meat and ideally topped with a sunny
side of egg and mixed in with a ton of
gochujang before i devour this entire
thing
are bts fun fact of the day is that bts
is the first kpop group to ever get
their own custom twitter emojis
for me growing up kpop was not seen as
cool
so the fact that twitter has
acknowledged bts with their own custom
emojis i feel like just speaks to the
global reach of bts and how
awesome it is that nowadays people all
over the world can listen to k-pop and
really enjoy it
so it is finally dinner time and one of
jimin's favorites
that is also korean staple is
kimchi-jjigae which is just a kimchi
stew
i figured since jimin is a meat lover i
would
make mine with pork belly apparently
jimin can't handle spice
super well even though he likes it which
is very similar to me so i always have
my rice on standby
so good
all alrighty good morning y'all and
happy j-hope day
j-hope is a literal ray of sunshine
and he's one of the group's main rappers
and dancers so graceful but then also
like hits
so hard when he dances but in terms of
taste he says that he really likes
traditional korean food so i'm starting
off my day
with some fresh kim pop that i just got
from the market it's a mixture of
veggies
sometimes some meat this one has fish
cake with rice and wrapped in roasted
seaweed it's
super delicious and great for on the go
it's so good because it's just one bite
of literally everything you want in a
meal
i also feel like i must clarify i've
seen people refer to this as sushi
on the internet it's not sushi kim pop
refers to
the seaweed kim is the korean word for
that seaweed and then pop is the korean
word for rice
another fun find at the grocery store an
iced americano
little hobie's face on it i actually
don't think i've ever had a nice
americano but
i feel like in every single k drama
whenever anyone's at a coffee shop
someone orders an iced americano
it's not bitter at all another
traditional dish that i saw jehovah
really enjoying on a v
live is kimchi bokkeumbap or kimchi
fried rice and i feel like an og way of
making it includes pork belly of course
your kimchi and some veggies
and topping it with a fried egg because
i'm a firm believer that a fried egg
makes everything
look and tastes better okay y'all i am
not a tasty chef
but i will say this looks pretty fire
look at how it jiggles this is another
one of those dishes that's great to make
when you just have a bunch of leftover
stuff in the kitchen because you can put
anything you want in your fried rice
okay j-hope is actually the only member
of bts that doesn't have his ears
pierced so hope you all appreciate
i took out my earrings today in honor of
j-hope while bts eats a lot of
traditional korean foods while at home
obviously they're on the road a lot and
apparently one of their favorite places
to come
when they're on the west coast is in and
out and i feel like in almost every
interview
j-hope mentions i love hamburger and
sprites
but however apparently i didn't do my
research well enough though because when
i came to in-n-out
they said they don't serve sprite so i
had to get seven up i'm sorry j-hope i
failed you but
can i personally taste the difference no
so
i will enjoy it either way i'm actually
here with my sister too
woo-hoo what do you think of the the
j-hope burger
meal it's just cheeseburger so it's
great
and today's fun fact is that bts almost
wasn't called bts
they consider the names big kids and
young nation before landing on
bangtan sonia so i'm glad they came to
the consensus that they did
welcome to v's day v is one of the main
dancers and vocalists for bts and he's
also just generally known for being a
hottie which i love for him
one of his fan appointed nicknames is
cgv literally standing for computer
graphics v
because they say he's too attractive to
be real
anyways i'm starting off the day with
one of these favorites which is
apparently
chop chip which is stir-fried noodles so
normally this dish is made with sweet
potato starch noodles which
i thought i had but i didn't have i
actually am using rice vermicelli
noodles which is not what you're
supposed to but i use the same marinade
and a lot of the same stir fried veggies
i will say it's not bad for my first try
ever making this the noodles are
actually seasoned with a little bit of
honey
or brown sugar so they have a slight
sweetness also some of y'all might be
thinking why are you eating noodles
first thing in the morning
noodles are always an appropriate food
to eat from the very random addition to
today's challenge i read that v
is a big fan of gucci k-pop groups wear
a lot of designer brands and
performances
and in general but since v has been
particularly vocal about his love
for the brand i asked my friend if i
could borrow her gucci belt
for today if this one thing will help me
feel one step closer to being that
eighth member of bts
you know i had to do it okay so it is
now lunch time and i feel like
i can't make a bts eating video without
including
which is korean black bean noodles
there's one very memorable clip that
stays in my mind of v
having to eat jaja mia silently
the kind he was eating kind of looked
like the instant ones chapagetti which
is
one of my favorite instant noodle brands
but i decided i'd try to be fancy and
make my own
inga actually has a video up on about to
eat showing how she makes it so i try to
follow a rendition
of that recipe so this is my version i'm
really excited i've never made this
before and it looks and smells bomb
this sauce i truly feel like there's no
comparison i can make to an american
version
it's so rich and creamy but the flavor
is just completely different from
anything i have in any other cuisine
another fun thing i learned about v is
that he actually didn't plan on coming
to audition
to be a kpop idol he came to the
auditions with a friend just to keep him
company and then
lo and behold actually turned out to be
one of the world's biggest pop stars so
it's dinner time i'm tired if you've
ever seen bts in an interview where they
ask where you like to eat when you're in
the states nearly every time
v will be very enthusiastic about one
restaurant particular
in that restaurant is panda express i
couldn't find exactly what v likes to
order when he's there
but panda express actually has tweeted
bts
and they use the hashtag love which made
me think
i better get orange chicken first piece
of orange chicken
in like years wow it is so sweet as
i was watching those interviews where v
would exclaim his love for panda express
and then a lot of times
interviewers seem confused and they'll
say something maybe along the lines of
okay panda express
came a long way for asian food but you
know it's probably not as good as you
get back home
to be honest i've never met an asian
person that considers
panda express to be asian food it's like
americans cosplaying
chinese food with panda express it's
still delicious in its own way but i
respectfully would not consider this
chinese food
and of course i couldn't envy's day
without giving a bts fact
and today's fact is that bts has broken
multiple world records and as of this
video their most recent world record has
been
most simultaneous viewers on a music
video and youtube premieres
with their video for dynamite suga is
one of bts's rappers and it's just
such a sweet little presence suga has
said that one of his
greatest simple pleasures in life is
drinking an iced americano on an empty
stomach
so before i eat anything i've made
myself an iced americano
okay i think i might have made it a
little weak but it's not
bad and for my actual breakfast sugar is
a big fruit guys
that's right baby we're eating hello
tangerines for breakfast today
you can find literal compilations of
sugar just eating
tangerines because he enjoys them so
much one interesting thing i learned
about suga's
name stage name suga it doesn't come
from like the sweetener it's actually
from his old position that he played
in basketball which was a shooting guard
shooting guard suga
if there's one thing that i feel like
bts constantly eats together and that
they say that they enjoy together
a lot that is fried chicken and beer
there's something about korean fried
chicken specifically just hits so
different oh my gosh this smells so good
if you've never had korean fried chicken
this is your sign
given that suga is a big meat eater i
figured that tonight was an appropriate
night to have kirby which
are korean marinated short ribs jasmine
has a great recipe for this y'all can
follow
however i just got mine pre-marinated
from the korean grocery store
even easier to cook and prep i'm so
excited because this smells
so incredible
you know what we haven't done yet today
our bcs fact today's fact is that unlike
a lot of other k-pop groups bts actually
writes their own songs and from my
understanding it's generally a
collaborative effort however
suga has been known to say that he is an
extremely prolific
songwriter being able to write songs in
one to two days which
literally just blows my mind okay the
day has finally come
for jyn's day i'm so excited because
jane is kind of like the notorious eater
of bts
he made his own mukbang eating show
called eat gin where he just bodies like
the most ridiculous volumes of food and
i love that for him
he's also one of the main vocalists for
the group and i think he has an
incredible sense of humor today's
breakfast i have to admit
i cannot guarantee is one of june's
favorite foods but it's very gin
inspired one of his philosophies around
food that he mentioned in an eat do an
episode was that
ramen seasoning the little packet makes
everything taste good
so i figured i would try to make
scrambled eggs
seasoned with ramen seasoning my eggs do
smell
a little bit like seafood ramen which is
which is interesting
but it's also like making my mouth water
my gosh it's not bad it tastes like when
you put an egg in your ramen
and you like scramble it in your soup it
tastes like that egg i think we can
deduce that gin was correct and that
ramen seasoning does make things
taste really good one of my favorite
things to watch gin
eat is noodles so i decided to make one
of his apparent favorites and that is
nangman which is
my childhood favorite it is a cold
buckwheat noodle soup and it's super
chewy
and satisfying you can make it from
scratch with the noodles and then a beef
based broth i just decided to get
another instant packet which is super
easy to make
very convenient and just as satisfying
in my opinion i like to top mine with
some veggies and a boiled egg
it's best on like a very hot summer day
it's just super refreshing
jen can probably shove it in his mouth
all at once the volume of noodles i have
in my entire bowl let's see how closely
i can imitate how
gin takes a giant bite oh
okay i immediately decided i don't like
shoving that many noodles in my mouth
like jin does but
it's very impressive that he can do it i
will also say one of my favorite things
about gin
just as a person because we know each
other so well is that one minute he can
be
shoving noodles into his mouth like his
life depends on it and then
he'll go into an interview and introduce
himself hello i'm jin
i'm a worldwide handsome given that he
was scouted for his good looks
go off gin but i would love to have that
level of confidence so jin strikes me as
a very fancy man because he says that
one of his favorite foods is lobster
class i'm sitting in my family's like
fancy dining room today
i know jyn has also said that he loves
steak and he eats three steaks a day
as much as i wanted to do that i thought
that i'd been doing a lot of beef
already so i decided to go with lobster
as like our more exciting option
i wasn't sure exactly how he likes his
lobster prepared so i was looking online
and there's a type of lobster that
is prepared you know and served as
regular street food in korea it's
seasoned with gochujang topped with
cheese
it looks super delicious so i tried my
hand at making that
very nervous to see how it tastes
but the cheese feels weirdly placed i
feel like it'd be better almost without
the cheese
it's probably my fault because i used
like gouda and cheddar instead of gouda
and mozzarella but
whoa little funky but i'm so good i'm
going to eat the whole thing and today's
fun fact is that bts's logo
since 2017 is made up of two trapezoids
it's meant to represent
two doors opening outwards and then on
the other hand
the logo for army bts fan base is those
trapezoids reversed so it looks like the
doors are opening
inwards and those two together are
supposed to represent bts
and army coming together as one which i
think is so lovely
and poetic of them it's very good
okay what do you rate it out of this
pretty good i would say
nice it is jungkook he's a dancer and
vocalist for the group and he's also
the youngest listen they call him the
golden magnet because
he's good at everything and for that we
have to stand
apparently he said that he's a big carb
fan and i've seen in a lot of behind the
scenes
clips that he likes bananas and peanut
butter
he made himself this delicious looking
peanut butter nutella banana toast
and when i saw that i was like oh my
gosh that's what i used to have after
school when i was a little kid
as a snack so i had to make it applause
for jungkook breakfast
given that jungkook's a carb lover i
feel like i had to make takboki which is
just a classic korean dish it's
literally
spicy rice cakes that are all stewed
together a little bit of fish cake i
like to add some veggies
and in all the eating compilations
jungkook's always eating noodles so i
had to add some ramen
it's a really common pairing in korea
when you get duck boogie you can add
ramen noodles you can add cheese on top
all these fun fixings so that's what i
tried to make
oh pretty good hey it's pretty good it's
my sister there's a lot of different
flavors going on we got spice
got a little bit of seafood we have the
sweetness
another random fun fact that i learned
about jungkook is that he actually is a
big fan
of body art he has i think over 11
tattoos i wanted to emulate jungkook so
i got a temporary tattoo which my family
will be much more on board with i got
this tiger one though because siberian
tigers are the national animal of korea
i am honestly really bummed this is my
last bts inspired meal
i know jungkook likes pizza i like pizza
so we're having pizza
in clips of bts having a little pizza
party together i know
rm mentioned something about a supreme
pizza so i figured a supreme pizza was
the way to go
pizza in korea is actually super bomb
you can get things like sweet potato
crust which sounds weird i think to
americans but it's really good
and just a lot of different toppings
that you wouldn't find in the states
as i'm enjoying this we might as well
share our final bts fact of this video
and that is in 2018 bts's album love
yourself tear was the first k-pop
album to ever top the billboard 200.
dinner is over
i have my dessert i know that jungkook
is a big fan of sweets especially
cookies
so i'm eating oreos and drinking milk
out of a bowl i think
it also seemed appropriate because
jungkook's character that he made in
collaboration
with line friends the bt21 line is
literally named cookie
so gotta end my week with some cookies
and
i'm looking back at the photos of all
the different meals i had
and they all look so good but there
could only be one winner
one ultimate day from this eating like
bts week
and my favorite day will probably have
to be suga's day
because ever since that day i have been
in love with ice americanos
and tangerines and you really can't beat
korean fried chicken though i will say
rm's day with the kaguksu very close
second
but please let me know which day you
would have liked to eat which bts member
would you like to share a day of meals
with and before you go oh my gosh wait
you dropped something
bye
you